друзі Всіх вітаю ось ці дні у мене і
моїх колег з Європейської солідарності
червоні телефони друзі з фронту
журналісти просто люди телефонують
запитують що у вас відбувається в
парламенті навколо чого були ці
штовханина дискусії крики дебати і таке
інше взагалі це ганьба що вперше в нашій
історії український парламент працює так
непрозоро і воєнний час тут абсолютно і
воєнний стан тут ні до чого це намагання
насправді сховати непрофесійність а
відсутність політичної культури і
безвідповідальність На жаль
монобільшості і на все це виділяється
150 млн грнь от щороку на канал ради
який показує радників офісу президента
пса
патрона що завгодно тільки не
транспарентну позицію і парламенту і
представництва всіх фракцій щоб ви хотя
би розуміли про що йдеться Які закони
обговорюються і що голосується ось
власне Минулого пленарного тижня було
два пленарних дні аж обговорювалися
зміни до бюджету 23го року необхідність
збільшити видатки на безпеку і оборону
одна з таких підтримок яку ми вже
сьогодні можемо забезпечити це збільшити
видатки Міністерства оборони на 211
млрдів на останні три місяці цього року
ці гроші будуть спрамовані на
забезпечення потреб збройних сил у тому
числі на грошове забезпечення
військовослужбовців на допомогу сім'ям
загиблих на закупівлю озброєння
величезна сума правда слуги його
абсолютно не слухали от Зверніть увагу
на атмосферу яка зараз панує в залі всі
Бродять лазять ходять жують плюють
спікер на це ніяк не реагує він робить
зауваження тільки європейській
солідарності коли ми апелюємо до його
відповідальності Таким чином додаткового
ресурсу враховано в законопроекті
недостатньо для задоволення потреб сил
оборони до кінця року законопроектом
передбачено лише 13 млрд тобто 4%
потреби європейська Солідарність на
відміну від слух уважно слухала міністра
оборони 250 мльрдів потрібно для того
щоб забезпечити виплати е в тому числі
курсантам сержантам пораненим збільшення
цих виплат на передовій і на закупівлю
зброї І власне ми уважно прочитали ці
зміни до бюджету на 23-й рік які
запропонували уряд і слуги якими більше
300 млрд виділяється на сферу не лише
оборони а й безпеки і ось в оце слово
безпеки вкладається ну дуже багато
несправедливих нечесних корупційних і
відверто лобійських історій поки в залі
хоч трошки є фракції слуга народу Я хочу
звернутися до вас от почуйте чому
категорично не можна голосувати за цей
закон причина номер один тут не тільки
оборона і подивіться що пишуть вже
журналісти
цитую бюрократи просять грошей собі на
зарплати прикрившись оборонними
видатками показую просто зокрема там
закладається збільшення фінансування
наприклад беб дбр а ці структури що
воюють вони на фронті Вони звільняють
нашу території чи вони тільки кошмарять
бізнес там закладається збільшення
видатків на секретаріятки Кабінету
Міністрів на Міністерство юстиції 100
млн запитали куди ці 100 млн ідуть і нам
відповіли на утримання російських
військово-полонених всі наші Кошти які
мають іти Сьогодні на збройні сили мають
іти на збройні сили і власне так Як
слухі Ну не читають те що вони голосують
не вдумуються вони ну знаєте якось
розбіглися відразу як мова зайшла про
поправки до проекту бюджету європейська
Солідарність підготувала близько 250
поправок до цього закону Звичайно це
ніякий не законодавчий спам і якби
парламент нормально працював тиждень
пленарний Ми би за кілька годин Це
розглянули разом всі прослухали А ще
важливіше якби на комітеті була прийнята
хоч одна поправка європейської
солідарності хоч одна але жодної нашої
поправки прийнято не було Е чому Ну тому
що слуги не слухають Да там мудрі поради
мудрі якісь пропозиції європейської
солідарності навпаки
Вони живуть в якомусь своєму світі і
настільки відірвані від нь від
реальності що що це просто лякає і ми
почули цей під час обговорення бюджету
на дитину пишу дитина
860 грнь на
місяць Будь ласка подивіться
860 грн на дитину на місяць
памперси система не витримує
грн
упаковка Скажіть мені будь ласка вот
будь ласка вот будь
ласка О я чую що тут колеги говорять що
це якісь не такі памперси ну це може не
ті які ви собі купляєте коли вас
викликають в набу Я не знаю може це
якісь інші але це теж памперси і це
памперси які коштують вдвічі більше
вдвічі більше ніж те що ми дає
Олексій я і не знав що ви є спеціаліст в
памперсах для набу ви і тут шикарно себе
проявляєте насправді європейська
Солідарність ми займаємо державницьку
позицію в тому числі в питаннях розгляду
бюджету очевидно що ми не популісти аби
в умовах страшного дефіциту бюджету
пропонувати напхати туди
нереалістичні статті на це грошей в
державі сьогодні немає але ми повинні
перерозподілити Кошти які є в держав
бюджеті із усіх корупційних і лобійських
статей забрати і передати на збройні
сили України ну з інших структур які
точно не воюють в першу чергу на
забезпечення збройних сил України а
також на ті соціальні статті які
сьогодні ну реально знаходяться в
глибокій кризі зокрема на освіту адже
очевидно що якщо ми не приділимо
сьогодні увагу освіті Можемо і в умовах
ну страшної демографічної кризи з якою
зіштовхнулися у Україна втратити цілі
покоління Це ненормально тому в менеє
пропозиція щоб ми зняли зараз 208 млн з
кабінету міністрів відправили на нашу
дуже чутливу категорію дітей сиріт А на
жаль жодна Пропозиція не була почута ні
під час розгляду поправок на комітетах
Ні в залі ми все ж таки ухвалюємо
воєнний бюджет чи бюджет управління якщо
збільшуються видатки на Верховну Раду на
Кабмін на офіс президента і все решта то
чому ми зараз говоримо що це воєнний
бюджет давайте знімемо зараз з камінак Я
пропоную 210 млн і направимо на інші
речі Шановні колеги зі слуги народу хто
ще залишився в залі вас небагато 32
людини на дану хвилину Але тим не
менше чому не можна голосувати за цей
законопроект підкреслюю в нас
виявляється армія в міністерстві
культури на неї виділяють стільки грошей
що Можна було б купити 184
мавіки на Міністерство юстиції виділяють
91 млн Можна було б купити 910 мавіків
Міністерство фінансів 272 млни
2727 мавіків поїхали далі Ну
Міністерство освіти і науки України там
підручники це святе але 47 млн ми тепер
розуміємо пішло на премії видатним
особистостям у сфері науки і культури ну
куди ще тепер що
стосується фонду державного майна
України от на них виділяють гроші
замість того щоб купити 431 мавік Ну нам
же дрони потрібні розумієте нам треба
рятувати життя людей а
в назва законопроекту говорить сама за
себе це про державний бюджет на
вирішення першочергових питань та
фінансового забезпечення сектору безпеки
і оборони Отже для фінансового
забезпечення сектору безпеки і оборони
пропонуємо 50 ль перенаправити на
Національну гвардію України і збільшити
видатки споживання загального фонду для
цього Дякую мені соромно що бюджетний
комітет і зокрема моновлада зараз не
хочуть додати елементарних 19 млн на те
щоби наші зв'язківці мали достатній
досвід достатню кваліфікацію і їх була
достатня кількість на передовій а
найстрашніше що парламент сьогодні
працює 44 пленарно дні на місяць при
цьому депутати отримують ну немалу по
нинішнім там міркам зарплату десь
приблизно 50,000 грнь це заробітна плата
плюс 50,000 грн - це депутатські
повноваження і очевидно ці кошти
потрібно відпрацьовувати потрібно
нормально вже повертатися парламенту до
роботи Вибачте війна в Україні триває з
14-го року і парламент весь цей час
працював два пленарних тижні на місяць
потім тиждень був в комітетах робота
тиждень в регіонах це нормально так і
треба працювати а не чотири там дні на
місяць ну безумство друзі У нас сьогодні
армія залишається без достатнього
фінансування Я ще раз наголошую що
міністр оборони заявив що не вистачає
250 млрд для того щоби закрити рік по
забезпеченню армії знаєте от скільки
виділили вони 211 млрдів так А де армія
40 ще візьме мільярдів де армія візьме
40 млрд І от саме навколо цих 40 млрдв
ми вели наш поправки тому що в цілому
бюджет було перерозподілено і збільшено
там видатки до
309 млрд грн і з них тільки 211 йшли на
збройні сили України А куди ще 100 Куди
ще 100 Ми намагалися просто цей знаєте
парад Я не знаю без відповідальності
зупинити але ну от кожне запитання воно
викликає якусь таку дуже дивну реакцію
Ну от послухайте є позиція комітету
хочетесь відреагути
Олексій Олексійович відпустіть мене
підвищувати
народжуваність дуже важливо відзначити
наступне що цей законопроект 138 який
розглядався зміни до бюджету на 23-й рік
іде Ну як в спарці в такій в спайці з
законопроектом 137 в якому Влада хоче
забрати податок на доходи фізичних осіб
які сплачують військові за місцем
постійної дислокації своїх підрозділів
от забрати їх з регіонів і передати в
центр
а мотивуючи це що в регіонах кладуть
бруківку неправильно використовують ці
кошти Вибачте абсолютно погоджуюся з тим
що кожна копійка має йти на збройні сили
України і у вас сьогодні у влади вся
правоохоронна система і як правило всі
оці Я кого ловлять там да на брукі
на хабарях це як правило з'ясовується що
це представники влади потім ми ж
усвідомлюємо як у нас Влада все витрачає
в центрі ми це бачимо починаючи з яєць
по 17 і закінчуючи тим що половина
сьогодні контрактів на які пішли
мільярди гривень мільярди насправді
гривень з центрального бюджету в тому
числі на
закупівлю зброї і забезпечення для армії
вони не виконані ці контракти і досі
немає жодних кримінальних справ досі
немає відповіді Де поділись ці кошти чи
чому немає е оголошених от для закупівлі
речей це теж ненормально І власне так
само цікавий момент от кошти від ПДФО
хочуть забрати з регіонів передати в
центр і при цьому не Міністерство
оборони а службі держзв'язку яка не є
навіть розпорядником коштів згідно
нашого законодавства от ми намагались ці
всі питання задати Владі і це викликає
якісь ну знаєте емоції замість того щоби
просто розказати так а що ви робите
позиція нашої політичної сили тут
наступна потрібно щоб ми дотримувались
закону податок на доходи фізичних осіб
його згідно законодавства він
залишається в регіональній Владі і
регіональна Влада вирішує як його
витрачати ідеологія наша що стосується
ПДФО ми пропонуємо щоби цей податок
згідно законодавства залишався в регіоні
на місці постійної дислокації частини
підрозділів які його сплачують щоби саме
на фінансування закупівлі зброї Дронів
ішли ці кошти за поданням цих частин
розподілялися місцевою владою А 30% щоби
залишалися в регіоні ішли на
бомбосховища на ремонт частин і місця
постійної дислокації військових
підрозділів Така наша ідеологія і хочу
але власне жодна поправка не прийшла Ні
до проекту бюджету на ну змін до бюджету
на 23-й рік ні потім от Верховна Рада
перейшла до змін до 37-го цього закону
по ПДФО знову жодна поправка не почута і
зверніть увагу тільки ми починаємо
переходити до поправок змістовних слуги
зразу чух і тікають з зали їм це не
цікаво абсолютно не цікаво якась армія
якісь регіони якісь переселенці якісь
підрозділи якісь податки Про що ви про
що ви говорите старі обличчя Ну от о
таке от ставлення до серйозної роботи А
ви знаєте от Подивіться будь ласка які
дивні потім в
такі пости виставили Голова Верховної
Ради його заступники АА
керівникмунобільшості де вони заявили що
е Незламна голова комітету з питань
бюджету вистоїла аж 8 годин за трибуною
відповідаючи на спамичний популізм
опозиції вона героїня молодець і
захистила бюджет там від зазіхань хоча
Насправді все навпаки мені здається що
це нормальна робота коли такі важливі
документи як бюджет приймається не в
турборежимі не в дурдомі оце тицну
кнопочку і все а з постатейним
обговоренням з обґрунтуванням тієї чи
іншої позиції і оцього професійного
відповідального діалогу не вистачає
катастрофічно нинішньому парламенту
очевидно що ключова робота по поправкам
маєти в комітеті і там потрібно виходити
з інтересів країни національних
інтересів країни а не з того хто автор
поправки бо якщо автор поправки від
європейської солідарності зразу все
відкидається вона а далі хоче трава не
рости і
по-третє мене подивувало звинувачення в
популізмі європейської солідарності яка
я наголошую запропонувала поправки не з
повітря а навпаки Це була ну
відповідальна позиція
перерозподілу Мені здається популізм це
трохи інше Це зараз в умовах воюючої
України видавати 2 мільр на марафон
Уявіть собі скільки це Дронів скільки це
броньованих машин скільки це виплат
військових але от 2 мільрд у них ідуть
на серіали
на олігархічні канали плюси да яким вони
просто сьогодні фінансують їх існування
за те що ті просто співають Алілуя там І
осану щодня владі Це ненормально є в них
там мільярди на дороги мільярди на беп
мільярди на казне що замість того щоби
перерозподілити ці кошти на збройні сили
України і от в цьому є проблема ми
займаємо іншу позицію ми вважаємо що є
ті видатки сьогодні від яких точно можна
відмовитися як буде зараз діяти
європейська Солідарність Ми чекаємо
підпису Зеленським законопроекту якраз
змін до бюджету на 23-й рік тому що
після цього можна подати наші пропозиції
чергових змін і ще раз спробуємо
принаймні 10 млрд перерозподілити на
збройні си сили України що тут не так
здається все правильно не дамо мовчки
під ковдрою в умовах війни Ну отак от
нахабно витрачати кошти платників
податків на речі без яких Точно ну можна
сьогодні було би державі якось пережити
отак от друзі будемо І далі розповідати
що відбувається в парламенті намагатися
роз'яснювати це тому що це важливо
підписуйтесь на мій YouTube канал на
канали моїх колег тому що там ну точно
більше інформації змістовної ніж в
марафонів